PROFESSOR: OK.
This is one more thing to tell
you about Laplace transforms,
and introducing a new
word, convolution.
And so we're going to
find our old formula
in new language, a new way.
But the formula is familiar.
And the problem is our
basic problem, second order,
linear, constant coefficient
with a forcing term.
And we know that the
Laplace-- and I'll
take zero boundary conditions.
So that the Laplace
transform is just
s squared y, sy, and that's
the transform of our equation.
No problem.
OK, now I'll divide by that.
So I move that as 1
over, and I call it G.
So this G is 1 over s squared,
plus Bs plus C. And that
has the name transfer function.
And then this is the
transform of the forcing term.
OK.
So here we have a nice
formula for y of s,
after I do that division.
It's a product.
The transform of the
solution that we want
is that transform
times that transform.
This is the transform
of the impulse response.
of the right-hand side.
Now I just have a Laplace
transform question.
Suppose my transform
is one function of s
times another function of s,
what is the inverse transform?
What is the inverse transform?
What function y of t
gives me G times F?
And I'm just going
to answer that.
The answer is the
g and the f, those
are the ones that give that.
But I do not just
multiply those.
The new operation that
gives the right answer
is called convolution.
And I'll use a star.
So right now I'm
going to say what
does that convolution mean.
So this is a general question.
If I have two functions
multiplied together,
then I want the
inverse transform,
then I take the separate inverse
transforms, little g and little
f, and I convolve
them, I do convolution.
And let me tell you
what convolution is.
So convolution is-- here is
the formula for convolution.
It's an integral from 0
to t of one function--
maybe I better use
capital T, better-- times
the other function, integrated.
That's what convolution is.
So what have I achieved here?
The same old formula.
The formula which we
described way back
at the beginning as
inputs f, growth factors
over the remaining time, g.
Put all those together
by integration.
Put all the inputs with
their growth factors.
Integrate to put
them all together.
And that is y.
So it's a familiar formula,
with only a new word.
But you see that I could
jump to the answer,
once I knew about the
convolution formula,
and I knew that this is the
function whose transform its--
let me say again.
Its transform is GF.
So if I multiply transforms,
I convolve functions.
And looking at it the other
way, if I multiply functions I
would convolve their transforms.
So convolution grows
the number of functions
that we can deal with
on Laplace transform.
Because it tells us what to
do with products, capital G
capital F. Or it tells us what
to do with little g little f.
So I'm almost through,
because I don't plan to check.
I could.
But this isn't the right place.
The book does it accurately.
I don't plan to check that
this statement is true
that the transform of
that one is that one.
But it is true.
But I do plan to do an example.
Now second degree
gets a little messy.
So let me do a first
degree example.
Example, I'll take the
equation dy dt minus ay.
That's our usual first
degree differential equation.
And I'll take e to the ct
on the right-hand side.
OK.
I'm doing those, because I can
take the transforms and check
everything.
So let me transform both
of those starting from 0.
So the transform of that is
s y of s, minus a y of s,
equals, well I know
the transform f of s.
I know the transform of
that is 1 over s minus c.
So this is just, s
minus a factors out.
So well y of s is 1 over
s minus a, and s minus c.
Again, this is the simplest
differential equation
with a forcing term that
I could use as an example.
So now I'm looking for what is
y of T. I'm looking for y of T.
And I'm now going to use
the language of convolution.
This is the transform
of e to the at.
This is the
transform of-- so you
see I'm thinking of that as
the transform of e to at,
and the transform of e to the
st. So there is one factor.
And there's the other factor.
So according to the
convolution formula,
I can write down the
inverse transform, the y
of t I want as the integral.
I'm just going to
copy the convolution.
But I know the
functions for that.
So it's an integral from 0 to t.
What do I have? g of t minus t.
What is the inverse transform
of 1 over s minus a?
It's e to the a t minus t.
And what is the inverse
transform of 1 over s minus c?
e to the cT dT.
So I have used the-- I've
just put in what I know
in the convolution formula.
And this should be
the correct answer.
And I can do this integral.
And what do I get?
Well, I'm pretty sure
that I get e to the-- down
below there will be
a-- you see I'm going
to combine those exponentials.
So I'll have a c minus a.
It comes out perfectly.
e to the ct, minus e to the at.
That's the right answer.
It's not only what the
convolution formula tells me,
it's what I know.
So that example is a good
one to show that when--
so I didn't use
partial fractions.
Normally I would separate
this into partial fractions,
and then I would recognize
those two pieces of the answer.
I didn't do that this time.
Instead of using partial
fractions, the algebra,
I used the convolution formula,
and did the integral or almost
did it.
We can do it.
And we get that answer.
OK.
So the point of
this video is simply
to introduce the idea
of a convolution, which
is the quantity we need,
the function we need,
when the transform is a
product of two transforms.
OK.
Thank you.